okay this one comes from sam ford
nice one i'm a big fan of ian
mcgillicrist i think he's perhaps one of
the most important thinkers of recent
times he cites jung a few times in the
master in his emissary and mentioned
ewing in his first talk with peterson
i've always wondered how well he thinks
jung's ideas about the different aspects
of the psyche map on to his own
he gives a little pulse amble it seems
to me that maybe the persona ego and the
left hemisphere may match up to some
degree
and that the unknown greater personality
of self matches up to the union
of the left and the right hemispheres
maybe
either way i would like to know his
ideas on how jung matches up with his
well that's a a very nice question and a
good one um
i have to say right away that i've not
really made any systematic study of jung
i read
modern man in search of a soul
when i was a teenager and it struck me
as a very important and powerful book
and since then i have uh
i've read bits and pieces here and there
so i don't really i wouldn't say i'm a
paid up jungian or anything like that
although i do find that
uh jungians like buddhists and i'm also
not a buddhist
although i have great sympathy with both
jungians and buddhists and they seem to
come to my um my talks and write to me
so obviously
in their probably better informed minds
um whatever it is i'm saying has
resonances and i'm always interested in
those
i think the the key thing about jung for
me
i can't really talk definitively about
things like the you know the ego and
the animus and the anima and all these
things but but i can
say that his general
world picture is very sympathetic
from my point of view
and one of the most important points
which is something that
he shared with goethe
[Music]
was this sense that opposites
uh come together and that's something
that i do strongly believe as i i've
said earlier when we were talking about
that
um so
yeah but i'm afraid i'm not really in a
position to it's slightly like the
freudian question you asked about you
know can we line up the id and the eager
and the super ego with
i think to an extent you can
but
and i'm sure that you know it's possible
to make good analogies
um between jung's uh
work which i don't you know as i say i
don't know the detail of
um
i've always thought of him as a very
sympathetic soul basically um
so i'm afraid i'm going to have to
disappoint some there um
but
the thing that interests me though is
you know that although
you see looking back over history there
are so many people
who
long before even freud and jung and who
knew even less about the structure of
the brain
than they did have posited
something very like what i'm
think i've discovered and i'm
promulgating from
the basis of modern neuroscience it's
very exciting that in a way these these
great archetypes these images from
wise minds in the past
they they had intuitive understanding of
something that can now be
more objectively demonstrated
you mentioned once in your book about
the greeks that they had
some intimation about the left and the
right hemisphere
either one is for
i think perception of the other one was
for
understanding
that's right
yes and and it's fascinating um
that so long ago people were speculating
on the the
um
the uses of the two parts of the brain i
mean what one has to remember is that in
in galen who is you know one of the
first great physicians he thought that
the brain was actually a kind of
air conditioning system he thought that
it helped the person lose
excessive heat so clearly they were very
long way off modern science but i i do
cite and footnote the sources for i
think the third century a.d
suggestions that the right hemisphere's
perception and the left for
understanding now unfortunately it's
actually true that the right hemisphere
is better at both perceiving and
understanding but one sort of knows what
was being got at the right hemisphere is
definitely better at perception
and at the sort of taking of things as
reality rather than um having
an idea about them in the way that the
left hemisphere has so you know it is
that is also remarkable thank you for
reminding me yeah
well thank you for pointing it out i
make extensive notes
okay
that's another reason when i was telling
you before that this podcast is killing
me in many ways
in one way
in a salutary manner hopefully in in one
way it's destabilizing in another it
takes so much preparation and hopefully
the preparation shows in the questions
and um
sometimes i read the comments and
often they indicate that they do but i
always wonder how much am i
overextending myself
no no well look i mean
let me say quite
genuinely that you do
your your questions are some of the best
um
they target very important areas and no
i think you're you know from that point
of view you're one of the best
interviewers that i've i've come across
so thank you